so is two that's a fun age sometimes
terrible twos yet or not yet she's Ador
well you might not I didn't get terrible
twos I got three Ager well I that's what
I'm scared is that it's just delayed and
I keep saying she's perfect and then
she's going to sneak up on me she's
super joyful meow was her first word but
her other word is no she's a totally
unreliable narrator she just know so
I'll say like she'll be eating
watermelon and I'll say oh is that
watermelon no
she's already gaslighting her she's
already gaslighting her kids are the
biggest G she does it with the cutest
voice it so now 15 years from now she's
been encouraged to act like this by her
mother oh my gosh I I love I miss I
don't miss as I love every age but mine
are seven and nine at this point and
it's like you just I was out
trick-or-treating with them and seen all
these little kids these little costumes
all it's very cozy very dangerous um cuz
I do not need more children um so
already a single mom but um so your boy
um you have one boy and two girls right
yes okay so I have a boy and a girl
that's very different are you
experiencing that my gosh when Hal
entered the equation it was like a we
didn't even know what to do it was like
all this boy energy that our house kind
of needed yeah you know cuz it was a lot
of girl things Vibes but boys are like
Tasmanian devils oh yeah yeah no he
leads with his head yeah I mean he was
also a New York City rat for Halloween
which is kind of awesome which awesome
the foreshadowing of that of who he's
going to be is pretty magical it's like
all right I love that he's not afraid to
be himself for sure yeah mine loves
scary and I think that's insane cuz he's
seven but he was like Mom take a picture
everything just horribly scary he was
like take a picture take video I was
like why we can look back over later
yeah yeah but he loves
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home